my next guest you know from his multiple
comedy specials on comedy central
uh he's got a new album out that is uh
animated thing i want to talk to him
about please welcome my friend kyle
kanan kyle did we have you
what's up buddy thank you for being here
uh
well not here anymore we used to be
neighbors and then you just
moved to uh portland yeah you saw me
posted up in front of the u-haul the
other day
yeah i i they don't like californians up
here so i
brought a lot of flannel i brought an
axe
just to just get in with my face yeah i
was gonna wear it
and then i was wearing it for like a
half hour and i lost enthusiasm for the
bit
it is weird i i what are you telling
people because the neighbors are asked
like what do you do and it's weird to be
like i'm a comedian
i moved from the entertainment capital
to here i don't ever tell anybody i'm a
comedian
what do you think i never want people to
know that because then then the
expectations on i just want to be like
hey that guy's pretty fun
and then because if they people know
you're a comedian and you're not fun
they're like this guy
sucks that guy with a super pac is
really fun
yeah i'm just kind of the guy like i'm
just watering the lawn up here they
nobody knows anything about me i've met
the neighbors the the mailman's already
seen me nude once that was a mishap
how's that happen well i'm not used to
living on the ground floor you know
you live in an apartment you're on the
second floor and this is nudity
all the time on the second floor because
nobody's looking nobody's cares
that's too much that vantage point here
i'm on the first floor
forgetting and living my life regular
and i thought i was
the laundry's in the garage and there's
windows on a garage door i haven't seen
that ever that's not city
life windows on a garage door get out of
here right well that's portland where
everyone like
has a roommate that lives in the garage
yeah well i was taking off all my
clothes
to put them in the wash in the garage
you know you're doing your laundry and
then you get to that point like well i
what if all my clothes are clean at once
oh yeah i've been tempted to do that but
the the uh
it's on the third floor so i have to
like walk down shirtless i don't be that
guy in the building but
that is a good thought now i'm in a
house
and i can finally achieve that
every single piece of clothing clean at
the same time
feeling so i i disrobe
yeah dunk the clothes i figured i got
three seconds
window just to dunk the clothes get back
in the house
that's the same amount of time that the
mailman is walking up the driveway
and i just he just i looked at him and
he
where he was wearing like some oakley
blades so i'm sure his eyes
saw it but i couldn't judge it he kept a
a straight enough look but um
that was like the first week we were
here so i don't know you got walked in
by the cool mailman who got into his
lifted mail truck
rolling coal out of the van did it take
a lot for you to move i mean first off
we
didn't hire movers and i don't know why
i could i could have afforded that i
just i like we'll do it ourselves you
know
wow stupidest thing i've ever done in my
life you pack
you pack so much stuff that you think
you're going to need and then after you
transport it
thousands of miles and you're like oh i
never i never needed this
i didn't i didn't need a i didn't need
this vhs uh collection of happy days
i have no less than 200 different
half full hotel moisturizers the
cheapest moisturizer it's always
lemon scented do you want to smell like
lemon smell like lemon and just be
slick for a good part of your day i have
so many of those
i think it's just white motor oil
there's no way it never absorbs
your skin your skin's like i don't want
that all the antibodies in your body are
like this shouldn't be in me
this why does this keep staining my
shirts this can't be good for my skin
this is aiming away at fabric if someone
just has a lighter in the room i
instantly burst into flames you smother
cotton balls with those for you to start
campfires when you're going camping it's
good yeah
i have uh three different lip balms just
on my desk
all packed these act unnecessary
i got i'm i'm ready i got like i said i
got a guy this is the first time
yeah did you get a gun because it's the
first time i've thought like i totally
have against gun control absolutely
there should be
a check but this is the first time where
it feels like
a good purchase it feels like yeah yeah
i bought a gun you know i bought a gun
because you ever look at the people in
line at the gun store
they're getting guns that's why i got a
gun yeah
this muffin top creep and a punisher
t-shirt's going to be armed
i'll lose i'm going to lose the civil
war but at least i want to lose with
some effort you know
it would make me feel more comfortable
if the guys buying guns were a little
more in shape
because they would at least try to do
the fist fight before
but this the line is like well that
guy's gonna go immediately for the gun
so he doesn't have to do stairs
yeah you're just indiana jones with the
guy with the scimitar in the marketplace
like he's gonna
shoot this guy like well come on man how
about a little fair fight
it starts with a roast battle i mean
that's what we can bring to the table
it should be a roast batter should be
able to take it and there should be some
sort of physical agility test that you
should take to be like you could
try to throw one punch at least before
you go to the gun
throwing stars that's a that's nice but
you are right and that is the
it's the people that are buying guns
it's like well then we want one we're
not going to be
like i have a sign i'm going to shame
you online
like that doesn't win there are going to
be like so
like in the next 18 months i'm sure
there's going to be so many like
different
i don't know like improvisers and tv
writers with
accidental bullet wounds
i wrote on caroline in the city and now
i have a small militia
operating out of burbank oh my god that
that went right through my air force one
i can't believe it
right through my new new balances it's a
weird time now you'd think you'd think
it would be easy to choose a side
because one of the sides
has nazis remember those those are back
you think you'd be like well even if
they got other stuff that's like meat
the nazi thing kind of cancels like wow
but free ice cream every other tuesday
hold on i love ice cream wait a minute
so you guys have nazis
oh man even if they check
every box nazis is still on there like i
gotta go to the other guy
it's it's the cartoon version it's the
first question on who wants to be a
millionaire like that's the obvious
joke answer is not the one with nazis i
already look like i'm in some sort of
bunker like i'm just peering out the
blinds
yeah they're coming man it's the mailman
there's no way he shouldn't have shown
up that time
he's in on it well that's what's funny
about the mailman is that he came back
the next day and i was out watering the
lawn and i had like a
joke 70s outfit from a party but i had
very limited clothing up here when we
were living here over the summer
so i was just saying cut off jean shorts
and like a a
red mesh tank top and i just look like
philip seymour hoffman's character from
boogie nights and i'm out there
watering the lawn and he comes rolling
up
and like all right now i look like i'm
just trying to court this fella
right like the housewife that's like oh
whoops you caught me
um hey there postman nice kitties
uh what was the idea behind portland
because of all the cities i mean a lot
of people make of the move to austin
not many people are going from la which
is not doing great right now to portland
which is
at least media wise not going great oh
i mean we're in the burbs so and i like
the burbs i grew up in the burbs
and when you grow up in the burbs you
feel like you're trapped and like
nothing good ever came out of there
but then i left and i lived my life and
now i'm back in the burbs i'm like i
dig this place people respect the
four-way stop sign there's good grocery
stores i got a grocery
store with a solid hot bar how do you
feel about the hot bar
moses i feel great until they start like
we have orange chicken
like i don't think vons knows what
they're doing with orange chicken
i really i would think anybody can do
orange chicken i would
i would question them when they're like
i would question vaughn's like this is
goat cheese like you just found that
cheese
yeah that's just goat cheese it's just
bad mozzarella but never once have i
eaten orange chicken and ever gotten a
hint of what i thought was chicken in it
oh yeah right
because it's all yeah it's all the
batter it's just
candy it's it's like movie candy
made out of poultry and i'm not that's
not a complaint
that's not exactly right do you think
it's gonna change your point of view at
all because a lot of stand up i mean
you're always on the edge
you're not living in great circumstances
your life is always on the road do you
think it's
and then now you're in the suburbs i
don't know i just maybe i need to let
that go but there is a thing like if i'm
too comfortable i can't do this
outdated medium that doesn't exist
anymore
what's the angle man oh there's just
some bum in the burbs now all right what
are you gonna talk about a podcast kyle
yeah but what what am i gonna do be the
50 year old who's still just amped up
and like oh man let me tell you in the
gristle hustle
bustle like i can talk about a fire pit
that i got in the yard if i can't make a
joke about
the fire pit and the stray cat that i
hang out with
then then i'm not a good comic if you're
a good comic you can you can talk about
whatever situation
i love grocery stores i've written jokes
about grocery stores i'll continue to be
your number one grocery store humorist
on stage
you ever see a tv dinner just abandoned
in the beer aisle
that's me can i go back to be
i am impressed at how long it took sona
to describe just what a cocktail was
like when you take alcohol yeah you
think but then you put it in a thing
that's not
alcohol like you like like it's two
different drinks but one's alcohol
but then you mix them together and then
that's like a different drink i'm like
that's the
do you think i waited the appropriate
time to slam dunk because i was like
maybe he's going somewhere maybe this is
a twist besides orange juice
sona wait till you meet a bartender they
are going to see me let's just post it
right to you
i would recall that let's just call that
mix a screwdriver i don't know
how'd you come up with that name i
pulled it out of my ass i don't know
yeah it took everything in me to not be
like
uh actually thank you for coming on the
show but
that exists i i i
adored the innocence of it you're gonna
have some interesting stories to follow
yeah so this year you put out an
animated album uh
trampoline in a ditch where if i'm not
wrong
essentially visual artists were able to
take your jokes or at least a segment of
your album
and do whatever they wanted with it
without you really meddling in it
yeah i kind of yeah it just turned out
great and i just told them to run with
it because like that's they're
i'm not going to direct them on how to
animate something they're the animators
go crazy with it
it turned out better than i could expect
do you have anything like what sona and
i were talking about where
sometimes if people animate you're like
okay well gut actually doesn't look like
that
but was there any notes like that or you
just couldn't no because i mean well
they were like
it wasn't user submitted they were
professional artists so i kind of was
you know relied on the professionalism
but
just doing stuff online with an active
colleague doing zoom shows with active
commentary it's the same kind of thing
where like oh i'm trying to do jokes and
then people get to comment on the screen
while you're
telling your jokes and they'll just say
something like
does he have a big head or just really
tiny arms and then
you just lay awake at night thinking
like wow both
i don't know yeah i haven't even thought
that far but okay
that was what i got when you're talking
about people commenting or drawing you
in a certain way
people will heckle through the comments
section
and you can't do anything about it
there's no get this guy out of here it's
like nope that's just a
one sentence that's gonna live with me
till the end of days i'll read that and
think about that
actually can't kick him out actually him
commenting whatever main thing
actually helps us yeah i guess now i
have to do pull-ups yeah
yeah there's a weird thing where it is
shifting where it feels really outdated
even next week the date i'm doing like
we kind of move past this like just a
guy talking yeah so
give him a give him a cartoon give the
folks a cartoon
so i'll give him a little cartoon to
watch you don't need to see me meander
around the stage
another guy that looks like this telling
you how he thinks the world works oh
good hope it's different because he's
got a red curtain behind him with some
purple light
and some smoke the smoke is nice it just
makes everyone look better
you know and it's a great foresight into
the future we'll all be performing in
smoke
you put effort into your backdrop i
should have i'm moving so that's my
excuse you talked me in six months and
it still looks at you
like this you'll know that i'm uh
depressed do you have big plans for this
room is it
this is the zoom room this is kyle tv
it's kyle tv is going down in here
i think start with the smoke machine
worry about the lights later but just
get as much
smoke in that room it just looks like a
hazard that's all it looks like like
all right well i can i can do about five
minutes tonight but i can't do ten
otherwise this guy okay every zoom show
every every appearance and we want you
to you know plug plug
manscape it's just covered in your
these forest house are uh i mean they
said we had to evacuate them like i got
this spot on hot tub tonight first so
after that then we'll get to find the
cat and get load of the car
i'll be getting a little high from the
smoke just because it's so oxygenated
just fireman coming in
hold on i need to get to my closer
something about how handshakes are i
remember guys i'm not gonna be shaking
against
well i hope to see important i mean if
i'm still alive and you're still alive
you should come out to the show hell
yeah man i'll do a little feature set
i'd love to get buried by someone that
features i'll take this axe and hack my
way through southeast portland to get to
the club
yeah yeah this is great this is a lot of
fun i think uh you should come back
is exactly what to have you on but next
time with more smoke more smoke
and me remembering that it was happening
right so i don't get high in the garage
first get high
what if everything i own was washed at
once
like parts in the dryer that's how it
happened and then i was going to take a
shower and every facet of my life would
be clean
it all solves it all right kyle cannae
thank you so much animated
album like the sections of it it's
called um it's it's
trampoline in a ditch right there's the
full album and there's some animated
stuff around there
thanks kyle it was great talking to you
man thanks buddy